okay I've got something very exciting to
tell you about so back in January we did
a fundraiser for the David Pakman show
and the idea was we want to do some
studio upgrades which we did we want to
do a new position called the progressive
engagement coordinator we had a long
list of stuff that we wanted to do that
campaign finished without raising all of
the money that we wanted so we had to
start picking and choosing what to do
and the entire plan was totally upended
by the YouTube advertiser boycott also
known as ad pocalypse which has been
going on since since it's sort of like a
day zero March 31st of 2017 but
something good still came from that
fundraiser that we did in January in
addition to the studio upgrades and some
staffing increases that we've been able
to make which is that Joshua Jarvis a
longtime supporter of the show selected
as his perk in this fundraiser ten free
memberships to give away now the idea
Pat was whoever selects that can give
away those ten memberships to their
friends or family or whoever they want
but Joshua Jarvis who's a really good
guy clearly has rido nated those ten
memberships back to us to give away and
what I've done is I have subdivided ten
free memberships into 20 half-price
memberships so effectively a path taking
out his protractor to figure out exactly
where we are on this we now have a
contribution from Joshua Jarvis which is
going to allow 20 people to get
memberships at half price Joshua has
already paid for half of your membership
right so your 60 dollar membership that
you might have been thinking about
getting half of it's already been paid
for if you want a half-price membership
and you can lock in that half-price rate
for as long as you want to keep it get
in touch with me through our website
contact form okay you go to david
pakman.com you go to the contact page
and you just say I would like one of
Joshua's half-price memberships Joshua
has paid for half I will send you a
coupon code which will allow you to sign
up for only 30 insects instead of $60
of the year and of course this gets you
the bonus show the world-famous bonus
show is an extra show that we do every
day it gets you the commercial free
audio feed of the show
it gets you the commercial free video
feed of the show it's tremendous and
it's first-come first-served Pat is not
allowed to participate Pat's family
members are not allowed to participate I
was going to say that my sister needs a
membership my uncle may need to well cat
won I was just going to take all 20 of
them I spoke to your uncle this morning
believe me we're working something else
out with him he's not getting any of
these half priced memberships not open
to show family friends I guess I mean
we've made a lot of friends through the
show so it's open to friends but not
family get in touch I will right back to
the first 20 people who say I want one
of those half-price memberships with the
coupon code
thanks to Joshua Jarvis you can send me
your thoughts about this or about
Democrats Inc or about anything else we
talked about today on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me they're
closing in on one hundred thousand
Twitter followers a lot of action there
you can also follow the show on twitter
at david pakman show